speaking of great toys I'm sure a lot of
you can relate to scrambling trying to
find last minute holiday gifts well do
not fear Don McCarthy of Don's corner is
here Don help us please well first off
I'm going to help us women and you guys
out there that want to get your
girlfriend something download this app
click her dot app it is amazing they've
got great stuff for the holidays and
you're like Don this is an app what
makes this different it's algorithm free
so it's not always going to come up from
all those curators that you may not know
about I'm tired of the algorithm exactly
so it's algorithm free they've got great
outfits for the holidays it's going to
help you on like what's on Trend what's
trending now they'd like we'll talk
about mixing patterns um it'll be what's
happening because like you have to wear
the same outfit it'll show you ways that
you can wear different things so guys if
you're looking for a gift also for your
girlfriend download this app this stuff
is going to cost you a little money when
you do but I love it that it's algorithm
free and it's a free to download so guys
you have no excuse of finding something
for your girls they have all different
model types
yes so do you belong to a book club by
any chance I don't okay well for those I
did it would be Oprah's okay well up
where you need to listen to this you
need to download this book so this is
Mother Knows words by Sophia Bella Roma
and that's sofiabellaroma.com it's great
she was an attorney at the holidays as
much as we love for them to have a great
time at the holidays and everyone to
enjoy there is sometimes some conflicts
and so this is about a mother-in-law
that can cause some a little bit of
problems in people's lives due to
cultural differences and stuff like that
at the holidays so this is going to help
you be able to just to kind of enjoy a
book but help and understand it because
we love the holidays they're so happy
but people going through divorce maybe
or separations and stuff this is kind of
a great book for you good idea next up
we need a stocking stuffer yeah and my
stocking stuffers are all about things
that I can use every day so this is
secret.com and this is our secret
waitlist dry spray It's Gonna Give You
48 Hours of protection all you people
out there in Las Vegas I know you're
going to a casino and go dancing and
sometimes don't come back back to the
next day so you're going to be good with
this they've reinvented this new scent
I'm going to spray it for you just so
you can smell smell that it's beautiful
it's got a wild rose they just
redesigned it there's no waxes no
alcohols nothing like that in it and
it's got that oil I saw that that's
wonderful it's got dry feel so you're
not going to feel all wet and everything
like that and I love it that it goes on
easy they redesigned it this is original
or green it so for all you cooks out
there this is an amazing cookware set 10
pieces are like under 150 this is by
Chef Marcel Vine your own he's been on
Food Network's tournament a champion
Bravo's Top Chef the Food Network's Iron
Chef it's non-stick lightweight really
affordable dishwasher safe comes in
these beautiful colors the white the
blue look at this rose gold rose gold
and it's so such a great gift to give
people whether somebody's getting
married at this time of season two and
stuff like that it's really affordable
Chef recommended Chef Marcel you got to
check him out too online
the really important gift here exactly
this is a present that every kid is
wanting this holiday is the hottest toy
this is powerpony.com and this is Mia
that's actually writing and she created
this when she was five years old it's
trending all over the internet right now
even some major celebrities have it as
their names
here
and so much fun we're gonna give you a
hundred dollars oh my God that is
amazing little toy here and I absolutely
love it it's great to write it feels
like a powered Pony because she always
wanted one it's the only powered
rideable Pony out there they come in all
different colors I called up to 250
pounds so you're clear Kendall you're
clear this is amazing okay so I have to
ask I know we don't have her mic'd up I
wish I could talk to her but what was
the inspiration she wanted a pony
yeah they didn't have space to have one
so these are just great gifts for
everyone in the family don't forget that
code fun like everyone's having and
Kendall have for a hundred dollars off
they ship actually you got to make it
though by Monday you gotta order a lot
of these products so that they can ship
in time by Monday oh my God this was
such a great spread thank you and
congratulations that is such an
inspiration to all the kids out there
all right and oh actually we have a
little more time
women you're going to love this I
absolutely love it because yeah let's
face it there's a difference in height
here so you can be able to find stuff
where it's going to reach whatever you
want on different clothes and what I
love most about this you have the
sequence and then you have the codes
exactly you've got a little bit of both
and like I said you can never go wrong
with stocking stuffer pots and pans like
come on update it's gonna be beautiful
in your kitchen even if you don't cook
because I don't cook what's on your
Christmas list give me one item
um a saddle oh a saddle makes sense